some of nevada's restrictions will be
lifted beginning monday there is a lot
to unpack here
we've got team coverage on what exactly
this means for
southern nevada businesses the i-team's
vanessa murphy leads our coverage with
the highlights from today's press
conference
denise and brian as you mentioned the
big takeaway here is restrictions will
start to be lifted
step by step over the course of 75 days
beginning monday
covid 19 numbers are going down the test
positivity rate around 14 percent
is still considered high but the
governor points to the state moving
in the right direction so here's the
plan on monday capacity limits will be
lifted ranging from
35 percent to 50 percent based on the
business or
activity so for example indoor dining
places of worship
gyms gaming floors and bowling alleys
gatherings will increase to a limit of
100
or 35 percent large gatherings can try
to be approved starting march
first on march 15th most businesses will
be allowed to operate at 50 percent like
retail stores hair and nail salons
gatherings go up to 250 or
50 percent of fire code capacity may
first
the state hands over decisions to local
jurisdictions
some people want you to open everything
up some people want you to close
everything down
some people want you to have no capacity
limits others want
strict capacity limits some people want
schools open
someone's school is closed every
decision that we've had to make
that i've had to make for the last year
has been fraught with
there's two sides to it it is a
difficult tight rope
balancing act to attempt to keep our
people as safe as we can by vaccinating
them
protecting our health care workers and
our hospital capacity and at the same
time
get our economy moving we've got
unemployment that's still too high
i've got too many people that are out of
work that are looking to go to work
and businesses that are struggling and
hanging on by a threat
the governor also giving an update on
vaccines
saying a total of more than 390 000
doses have been administered statewide
we know many nevadans are frustrated we
are still in the 70 plus
age group for the covid19 vaccine there
are
long lines there's disorganization i
asked the governor about this
more on that at six and the governor
also pointed out that
16 out of 17 counties in nevada have
children
back in school clark county the largest
school district
does not he pointed this out that more
than 300 thousand kids haven't been in
classrooms for more than a year
he expressed support for getting kids
back in school